the boys have decided that you know
they they're they're not seeing her
right now it's been a few months since
they've actually even seen her
Kevin's better a line who is Britney's
ex with whom she has two teenage Sons
recently did some interviews about
Brittany where in the interviews Kevin
said that he was doing this because he
cares for his children and he did it
under the guise of this is all for the
right reasons but of course fans were
incredibly upset about this the general
consensus from our readers and from
social media users that I have
interacted with is why would k-fed do
this publicly you are dealing with
children you are dealing with the mother
of your children and your ex-wife this
is something that should be done behind
closed doors I just try to explain to
them that
she your mom needed help you know and
and the people were in play to try to
make that happen to make it better we
all have this First Amendment right in
in the United States to give statements
and render opinions and it's very
difficult to you know stop somebody from
speaking and or to punish them from
doing so this is doing nothing but harm
to the children in their relationship
with their mom this is doing no good to
resolve that Britney's lawyer spoke out
against Kevin Federline very strongly at
the time I had reached out to Matthew
Rosengard for a statement and he said
that he usually does not comment on
personal matters with Brittany but this
was just so egregious for the father of
her children to go on TV and to give an
interview about her that he felt that he
needed to make a statement to condemn
those actions and I think it's safe to
say that fans around the world agreed
with sent to me
I can't
report to speak for Brittany and her
feelings I think it's really unfortunate
that some members of Britney's family
and and
team have
sort of put out all these stories
throughout these years and sort of
painted a picture of her that may or may
not have been true and and most
importantly it wasn't her own
representation of herself and now to see
her come out authentically saying this
is me this is who I always wanted to be
we don't care about her family who may
be saying these things that are hurtful
or untrue we just support her at the end
of the day